las empresas hoy en día es godoy trabajo
tranquilo soy vicepresidente de esta red
y bueno estimados pongan servido por
favor los que están sentados arriba ya
la hora de almuerzos a próximas y que
iban a destinarse relación son poquitos
por favor
cierra sus ojos
imaginen
cierra sus ojos e imaginen un científico
como es este científico que ya tiene
donde trabaja
con quién se relaciona aquí lo tienen a
su mente su plasmar esa idea
abra sus ojos
y aquellos que hayan pensado en el
profesor de volver al futuro le haga
tomar asiento
el que haya pensado en albert einstein
también el que haya pensado
stephen también el doctor de breaking
bad también cientos e iniciales personas
igor y también entonces ya ok ahora
tenemos al grupo de los científicos
jóvenes en la siguiente imagen no sé
cuántos pensaron que ellos podían ser
sanz tibios o científicos joven haciendo
ciencia fuera de un laboratorio bueno
si lo vemos en cifras actualmente
la educación en latinoamérica para niños
de primaria y de primaria y secundaria
educación básica y media
no es algo importante muchos de ellos no
tienen este concepto de científicos
joven dentro de sus mentes si lo
pensamos bien en chile uno de cada tres
jóvenes no tiene las competencias
científicas mínimas para desarrollarse
en la sociedad y además de eso dos de
cada cinco personas consideran que la
ciencia y la tecnología no son
agente de impacto social
entonces con estas cifras tenemos harto
para pensar hay trabajo aún por hacer en
materia de educación científica
cuando estaba en el colegio
casi al terminar mi enseñanza media
puede acercarme un poco de este mundo
científico alcanza a conocer parte de lo
que el gobierno el estado actualmente
hace para difundir la ciencia
la educada educación escolar
alcancé a llegar a una instancia
nacional donde llegaban los mejores
trabajos de investigación científica
y ahí se disputaban los mejores para
buscar quién era el mejor de los mejores
para representar al país en ocasiones
internacionales bueno conocidas
científicos de renombre lo motivaron
bastante a poder seguir en esto de la
ciencia y cuando ellos me hablaban veía
motivando cada vez más
posterior a ello sería motivado
quedé seleccionado en un campamento
científico de carácter internacional
el fin de este campamento era
formará la próxima generación de jóvenes
líderes jóvenes que quisieran impactar
la sociedad a través de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemática el
fin de esto es transformar la educación
científica no sólo en chile sino también
en latinoamérica
el lugar tierra del juego como pueden
ver en imágenes
hay un laboratorio el lugar era indómito
un parque nos recibía con los brazos
abiertos para hacer nuestro laboratorio
un laboratorio natural
personas comunes y corrientes que tenían
gran interés en ciencias nos enseñaban
uno u otro concepto ellos impactaron mi
vida de gran forma dejar mucho más
motivado de lo que ya estaba después de
haber pasado por este ansia de
competencia escolar
pero se aproximaba a la universidad y
esta motivación seguía posterior a este
campamento llegué a la universidad y en
mi primer año decidí embarcarme en una
experiencia que sabía que me iba a
motivar mucho más y me voy a impactar
estaba seguro de ello conseguir ser
monitor de un campamento campamentos
científicos con fines muy similares al
que participe en este campamento tenía
igual la misión de transformar la
educación científica generar impacto a
través de stem a través de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas
el grupo era diverso los chicos eran de
quilicura ahora como una ubicada en
santiago de chile
de distintos sectores distintos colegios
no se conocían todos le daban entre 13 y
17 años
pero tenían un interés en común la
ingeniería y la matemática
el grupo que me tocó monitorear
particularmente tenía el interés en
física
este interés lo llevó a practicar
experimentos sacar sus conclusiones en
base al método científico
no obstante en este campamento que les
mencionó se les hizo la misma pregunta
que ustedes cuales estudian típico ideal
cómo es que hace en primera instancia
ellos respondieron en dibujos algo que
estaba cercano a lo que todos pensamos
que es un científico de sexo masculino
de edad avanzada en un laboratorio con
un delantal y está algo loco
pero lo que al final del campamento
podemos ver es que no solamente
consideran científico aquel que estará
un laboratorio también consideraban
científico aquel que le da una charla en
el campamento aquel que estaba como guía
de monitor
aquí el que estaba a cargo del grupo y
no solamente eso también ellos mismos se
consideraban científicos
esto en otras palabras las ciencias para
todos
cualquiera puede hacer ciencia
vivir y respirar sin acción un
campamento de los impactos al igual que
mí
actualmente
estoy trabajando
en una red
tiene por objetivo impactar a la
sociedad impactar a la sociedad de forma
positiva a través de stem
a través de ciencia tecnología
ingeniería y matemática
la red es variada está repartida a
través de todo el cono sur a través de
latinoamérica algunos estudiando y lejos
de acá
que nos mueve
genera un cambio en la sociedad un
cambio positivo a través de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas
ahora bien usted es público
a su diario vivir en lo cotidiano como
quieres impactar a la sociedad gracias
[Música]